welcome to the heavy welcome to the
across the Spoilers Podcast sorry guys
habit there I'm your host Paul AKA Pooh
Barrymore we've got a lot of stuff to
talk about this week we're just gonna
rattle through it because there's so
much things going on um but good news in
terms of the strikes apparently the
amtpt or whatever it is and the wga
they're meant to be meeting on Wednesday
to finally bring an end to this strike
it's been about four months I remember
back in about was it may I want to say
when we first got Rumblings of this I
mean it was back when they were we were
filming Deadpool 3 and uh the Panic that
started to set in with us because we
were like oh crap it's gonna be another
sort of delays pandemic thing
um and that's kind of where we're going
with the the stories these days but
we'll talk about it in a bit Drew
Barrymore a bit of a clue about what
things were gonna go gonna go into that
but uh yeah Greg how are you feeling how
are you doing dude I need this podcast
right now Paul and I have had personal
life Conquest this weekend
and nothing is more important than what
we have to discuss today we must escape
with movie news today I'm excited all
Haunting in Venice came out
yep so
I don't think you really missed much by
uh not going to see it the box office
it's 14.5 million domestic and 37
million globally and the prediction is
that it could lead to a 100 million plus
theatrical run which is not very good
um and this is kind of I feel this was
sort of impacted by the pandemic
retroactively because I I quite liked uh
murder on the Orient Express and then
death under the Nile that obviously came
out that was one of those films that
they dropped on streaming and the cast
they were a bit problematic and um
something's actually happened the last
week that's added another person in
there we're not really going to go into
that because we want to keep things uh
very light-hearted but it's a developing
story at the moment controversial Gal
Gadot all her fault um obviously she
released the Imagine video during the
pandemic but you know I feel like that
film kind of killed the interest in this
one almost because I saw the trailers
and it looked really good but I think I
was just kind of like I I'll just wait
until it hits streaming and obviously
you know there's probably a lot of
people out there it's the third Poirot
movie
um so yeah it's kind of kind of quite
badly underperformed I don't think we'll
get another one after this now the nun
two has crossed 150 million at the
worldwide box office on a 38.5 million
dollar budget so doing quite well you
know it's made its money back more than
10 folds uh I don't think it's more than
10 full well we're not you haven't come
for maths let's be honest uh but it's
made it's money back at least so well
done guys
um horror always seemed to do really
well in these situations and I don't
know why Hollywood just doesn't pump out
more I suppose October we've got a lot
of horror films coming out kind of
dreading The Exorcist sequel
um I just bought the 4K version that's
just released of the original
what a movie
um great little great little film that a
lot of stuff going on with it and
it's over 50 years old at the moment
actually as well it's it's just had its
50th Anniversary I think which is
absolutely crazy when you think about
and how much of an impact and influence
that films had and it still feels when I
was watching it it still feels like it
was released quite recently like in the
80s I understand for a lot of people
that the 80s isn't that recent but when
someone says the 80s to me I just
automatically think 20 years ago because
I'm a naughty kind of kid and but for it
to have that impact where 50 years later
we're still getting sequels to it and
obviously their sequels are spread out
shows how well that movie's done um but
yeah there's lots of things coming out
in October that I am so I'm excited to
see others not so much now Blue Beetle
has also grossed 1.7 million on its
fifth weekend overseas which is just a
32 drop from last weekend and it's just
debuted in Australia
so it's added 67 million in the US
um and it's hit 100 and
119.9 million glow I don't know why all
these numbers are going from but they're
saying it's basically going to make uh
135 million Global run so I don't get
whether 1.7 Millions come from but lots
of numbers we're throwing out at you
there uh yeah Gran Turismo the Sony box
office video game film has finally
crossed the 100 million dollar Mark
globally
um and that was because it debuted in
Japan which gave it a 1.3 million debut
so yeah lots of films coming out I'll be
honest with you Greg haven't seen many
of them haven't seen any of them really
to be honest except Blue Beetle but uh
yeah well I bought this pink shirt
because I did a reaction to Barbie last
week and I finally saw barbie and I
liked it a lot and ladies and gentlemen
in the comments it's still even though
it's on video on demand it's number one
video on demand right now at least
according to Amazon Prime
we got to convince Paul to watch it I
think you actually enjoy the movie man I
really do I think you'd enjoy it please
watch it watch it with yourself okay
well your wife not the kids they won't
get it they're too young I feel like I
kind of have supported the movie in a
way though because that Dua Lipa song
I've listened to that about 4 000 times
at least at least it's a banger it's a
banger my dog's gone crazy in the
background guys so sorry if you can hear
that it makes it for realism and that's
what we're all about here the realism of
a conversation so Haunting in Venice I
think is a really interesting
flop because I remember the TR I was I I
didn't watch the trailer online
um I saw it in the I saw the trailer I
forget what movie it was for but I I
think it might have been for across the
spider verse and the trailer played
and then Kenneth Branagh appeared at the
end of it and the and that was the only
trailer I saw and and for me I was like
oh dang that's a surprise that's cool
and I feel like maybe that worked
against it to a certain extent because I
think audiences might have I I feel like
he's the lead and he's he also I didn't
even know he directed it until recently
and to me I only registered it as he's
probably just a a cameo in the movie or
a really small role I didn't realize it
was oh a full-on Hercules Perot movie
and maybe that could have helped boost
the box office performance granted the
Nile didn't do so well maybe they wanted
to lean into the marketing in this very
specific fashion with leading with the
genre The Ensemble and then Hercule to
show like this is something different
however I didn't fully register it as
thus the the number three out of this
murder on the Orient Express you know
franchise trilogy but it's probably
killed the franchise
um but I heard good things about it man
people people actually liked it and I I
want to see it but just don't have the
time for it and of course you know none
too those I think what horror really
proves is that it's the it's the one of
the few genres because one of the big
talks with horror is you can do things
that are low budget and make like
massive profit you know you uh you just
covered talk to me which was done on a
low budget but made a a really good
amount of profit considering what the
budget was I just saw it because of your
recommendation love that movie by the
way uh thank you for encouraging me I
wanted to watch it already because I
love those directors but dang wow what a
movie really I've been thinking about it
like non-stop really good movie and uh
but but we've had a lot of conversations
you know in the Zeitgeist about the
mid-budget range film does not exist
anymore and it seems like the only time
and I could be wrong about this numbers
are not our expertise here but we often
talk about them is that horror seems to
be the one thing where mid budget can
actually pan out specifically these
Warner Brothers mid-budget films things
like the It movies or uh The Conjuring
franchise it's the one genre that seems
to thrive in the mid-budget range where
everything else is either super low
budget or really over inflated now and
so I think there's some success to be
celebrated but yeah I mean the looking
at what happened haunting and Venice
that's another Disney movie isn't it
it's Disney man they're having it really
isn't it Disney or is it Fox am I wrong
about that I gotta look at it I mean
Disney's in are the same thing now
to be honest so yeah that doesn't really
make a difference
um but yeah horror is just completely
always kills it I mean if you look
historically at the films that have had
the lowest budget and made the biggest
profit it's pretty much all so it's 20th
century Studios made it so yeah it's
another Disney flop um which congrats
guys great yeah great yeah so far you've
managed to I'm sure your shareholders
are over the moon but um yeah so it's
Horror in general and you think about
Paranormal Activity The Blair Witch
Project which I think both of those
films for a lot like Blair Witch at one
point was
it the lowest made movie that made the
most money I'm weird in that terribly
but you know what I mean so in
comparison to its budget if you
multiplied it to get the profit returned
completely Bonkers same with Paranormal
Activity and yeah a horror a lot of the
time is down to marketing and how they
kind of pitch it like oh and a lot of
the time you know those two movies used
very similar marketing based on the this
really happened and we've got video
footage of it it's like oh did it really
happen though but that's how they Market
it and you know people turn out on
droves to see a true ghost story
um so yeah it's it's such a it's a great
genre that you can really get creative
with and a lot of directors that go on
to make bigger projects often get their
start in horror and yeah Haunting in
Venice just didn't really seem to tick
with the horror group and I don't know
why because when I saw the trailer took
me ages to realize it was a Poirot movie
and but maybe I kind of sunk in and
Horrors had a bit of a weird weird yeah
because obviously
um the last Voyage of the uh demita or
Dracula on a boat as I affectionately
call it that didn't do very well either
so yeah we're starting to see perhaps a
shift there's actually lots of horror
movies coming out in October like I said
so we'll see if they cannibalize each
other or if you know people just
continue going back to the cinema and
that I think that's really going to get
kick-started with saw X which is coming
soon not the kind of horror I'm into and
but we'll see how it does and yet lots
of things I've seen them all man I've
seen every song really I'm excited I
have as well yeah but I'm just not into
the whole watching people get like the
neck Twisted round until the head comes
off and stuff like that just it's in my
bag of just more yeah more Supernatural
stuff um so show your kids Barbie show
them saw X I feel like that's the way to
program them at a young age Paul to make
them men at an early stage in life yeah
you know thinking of Haunting events
it's probably just marketed really weird
too like what it it doesn't seem like it
serves the audience who watch murder on
the Urban Express and Death on the Nile
and it's and if you're like a horror fan
maybe you thought it was like posturing
as horror but really wasn't you know
what I mean I I don't know it's kind of
a strange thing but yeah what's what's
next on this list man what else do we
got another big success actually in the
box office as well uh Joan which is an
Indian film that's just crossed the 100
million dollar Mark globally
um haven't had a chance to see it yet
you know haven't been to the pictures
but yeah well done guys you know RR that
was a you guys are just killing it
constantly and it's nice to see your
your entire film industry getting that
recognition because you guys deserve it
always make good good quality films and
yeah I'm excited to see that when I when
I can when I get a chance to see it and
but yeah holding in Venice it's probably
going to cancel the series and speaking
of things getting canceled Drew
Barrymore had a lot of stuff going on
this week
um so she announced that she was gonna
be bringing back her talk show
wga uh we're like well what the hell's
going on mate that we haven't ended the
strike yet
um so obviously she got a lot of
backlash and people like Anson Mount for
example he said that you have undermined
the Integrity of the Union full stop I
refuse to believe you didn't see this
coming all you have accomplished is to
extend the strike as you've now handed
the amptp a glimmer of hope that the dam
is breaking thankfully it's not so she
released an apology video did you watch
it Craig what did you think about it I
love a good apology video
look Drew Barrymore to me I'm not going
to pretend that I actually know this
woman 99 of us do not know who she
actually is from the personality that
she has put on display and how she's
been in interviews and whatnot on the
way we tend to associate her personality
is that of a very emotional sensitive
and pathetic individual
so do I believe
that her emotions in that video sure she
shouldn't have started crying though at
the same time it's like what if you're
gonna do an apology video like that if
you wanna if you really want to just own
your choices you got to be direct
straightforward and if you do anything
that hints as
you are a victim of some sort in this
situation even though she does not
declare that the way it can translate
when you're getting very emotional about
said decision it comes across like a
little bit of victim mentality of us and
it's like she's in a weird way with
saying I know what I'm doing is not
making people happy and is probably not
right I'm not saying whether it is or
isn't it's she's saying it's probably
not right but I'm gonna do it anyway it
was not a good look
what I am not a fan of right now though
from this update that she has decided to
not return is the people who are still
condemning her because I I can get it if
you were really against what Drew
Barrymore decided to do with her show
fine now that she has decided to not
return if you were against her prior I
think we gotta just let it go there's no
need to crucify the woman she has made
the decision that ultimately the
industry wanted her to make
it's like it's a talk show so sure I I
think with a talk show the last thing
especially something like hers like for
me when it comes to a talk show I'm more
into the conversational pieces that
don't feel like a writer might have been
involved or not right you know just like
the interviews whenever I see clips of
The Drew Barrymore show it's just her
it's like a clip from her like with an
interview with a celebrity like the
Keanu Reeves interview I thought was
great
but writers are essential to a show like
that uh you know when it comes to the
monologues when it comes to writing
questions research for your guests
that's all very important stuff and is
there a world where she could return
without you know
um enlisting non-union writers and just
being able to do the show without
writers yeah does that make it within
her right to return
sure at the same time I understand the
wga concerns over that because while it
might not be directly performing the
work of a striking work of a striking uh
worker
in a lot of ways by her returning it can
still be looked at as undermining the
strike I think there was even a photo of
her head writer uh picketing as well
outside of it for what what was going to
be happening
and it's like regardless man you know
even if it is within her right a lot of
this situation is a massive Optics game
Drew Barrymore is clearly sag I've
always known her as a highly prolific
actress I've only seen clips of her talk
show a lot of people didn't even realize
she had a talk show until this news came
out
so the Optics around this particular
situation
what publicist is going to want their
celebrity talent to go on this show you
got to think about the long term of that
if if the conversation around if there's
too much controversy where there's so
much industry people and and when you go
online and everyone's just saying well
there are people in support of her it
seems the predominant point of view has
been you are scabbing to some extent or
you are not respecting your writers
I'm talking about the Optics again
there's no world here where I could feel
like long term if you want your show to
continue to succeed
that
this would be the right call she made
the right call to ultimately go you know
what I made a mistake by deciding to
return I'm not going to because her show
needs guests that's one of her many
things about having to talk show it
needs to guess and the talent and if
you're looked at as scabbing in any
regard or if that is the Optics around
the ship because then if you're a talent
who goes on the show where everyone's
like she's a scab then you are looking
like you are in support of the scabbing
side of things as well so yeah I think
that uh it was not a wise call and while
I think
perhaps maybe her intent I'd like to
give the benefit of the doubt that her
intent was you know coming from the
right place to take care of her workers
and whatnot
and while I do agree with that because
you know below the line workers they're
not going to get residuals and when
it comes down to it
ultimately it was yeah for to keep the
show on air and for long term and of
course with the support of the writer's
Guild yeah it was it was the right call
to not return yeah when you when you
think about the scales of the situation
it just made me think she's a fire
starter and it made me want to scream
and maybe do 50 First Dates to get get
through to uh you're doing the wrong
thing Drew but I totally agree with what
you're saying I think if someone makes a
mistake and they apologize then can you
really hold it against them when they
change their ways you can but you
shouldn't really because then what's the
point in them why should they even
listen to you in the future if you're
just gonna still hold it against them
and so obviously there's more serious
things uh in the situations where that
doesn't apply but in terms of just
making a TV show
obviously she shouldn't have done it and
I think the fact that you know we've
seen Bill Maher also do the same thing
so he did announce that real time was
coming back without writers and actually
during the last strike um he was
obviously doing a show back then as well
he didn't have the monologue and he just
kept working and I think he felt like it
was a similar sort of situation
obviously there's a lot of jobs in this
industry that in aren't just writers or
actors there's cameramen crew editors
producers and they're all unable to work
as well so I think they kind of just
thought like we need to get these guys
paid
um and that's why they did it but now
both have announced that because the
negotiation tables they're back on real
times getting suspended as well and
hopefully everything can get worked out
very soon I'd actually just like to to
shout out
um John Oliver as well who while they
were seen as scabbing Drew and Bill all
of John Oliver was out doing live stand
up to pay for his striking staff so they
could keep on striking so top bloke from
Britain Great work
um and yeah he just he just broke
everything up now speaking of breaking
things up Jonathan Majors uh last week
he had a he had he was walking along the
street this is a this story I actually
believe this is what happened but anyway
there was two girls fighting you know
they're having a fight in the street
Jonathan Majors walks in like it's like
he's Chris Pratt from Jurassic world he
puts his hands up he breaks up the fight
um and yeah
lots of people obviously looking at it
thinking and scene should be set at the
end they thought it was fake personally
I don't and that there was a second
account that came forward with a
different angle of the situation that
played out and it looked you know it
looked real I might you might have just
slipped the ball like 50 or something
um and got them to do it but I thought
it looked real oh there is that back and
forth and obviously there's a lot of
things surrounding Jonathan majors at
the moment and which I'm sure you guys
are aware of completely now Boris
Johnson
I don't know if you're aware Greg but in
the UK there was um Boris Johnson before
he got elected as prime minister he had
a big bus behind him he was going
through the country talking about how
great brexit was gonna be and they had a
figure on the side of a bus uh lots of
350 million I think it was they said
they'd save and give to the NHS by
leaving brexit something along those
lines and then it obviously hasn't
happened but then a couple of years
later Boris Johnson in an interview they
were saying well what to get up to in
your spare time Boris and he started
saying well I like painting buses mate I
paint buses and the theory was that he'd
said this thing so that when people
Google Boris Johnson bus that story
would come up instead of the whole
brexit controversy now a lot of people
have thought that when people google
Jonathan Majors fights girl that what's
gonna come up is this video of him
breaking up a fight instead was it a
masterful piano Greg was it real what's
happening oh man
I mean I saw the one I didn't see the
second angle you're talking about it
looked faked it looked stage to me
but I I'm like what what would they have
to pay these teenagers
for two girls to beat the crap because
that the the hitting and all that that
looked real you know and YouTube we are
just talking we are not showing any
footage right now I want to make that
clear to YouTube uh we were just talking
about something
so that that part looked real to me
um but yeah I mean the way he stepped in
kind of looked like a I don't know if
somebody a music video
look like Michael Jackson's Beat It
music yeah that's that's kind of what I
thought of in that moment and maybe it's
real maybe maybe it's not it's it is
kind of I think it's really funny what
you said though I didn't even think
about that part of the conversation I
can't get over that that's that's so
funny uh
I'm not here to declare whether or not
it is what I find interesting though is
I just learned
so right now what Jonathan Major's
attorney did is they filed a motion to
dismiss the case right
and uh the next hearing is scheduled for
the original release date of Loki season
two episode one which was October 6th
and that is when the judge is expected
to rule on the defense's motion to
dismiss
the motion is denied trial begins
October 25th
Loki season two finale
Loki season two they just announced
today of the time of us filming this I
think uh today or yesterday or something
like that that it's actually going to
air now
October 5th
6 p.m Pacific Standard Time 9 p.m
eastern time so they're gonna air it
earlier now the one might go oh because
of Ahsoka yes I would think so because
that that time frame has clearly panned
out for Ahsoka
it is very interesting though that they
have officially moved it the day before
us to be like
look we gotta just hook the viewers
either way even if the trial is not
going to go in Jonathan Major's favor we
don't know
let's just release this at least the day
before the trial that way people will
already be like well
I already started the show so I even if
it doesn't pan out in Jonathan Major's
favor I've already started and I'm
committed to watching it now so let's
just do it that's a really fascinating
yeah so I personally think that they've
moved it because of the Ahsoka time slot
obviously this trial was gonna hit I was
meant to get sorted out earlier in the
year I think but the Clayman didn't show
up or attend or something unless they've
had to push it back
um I'm guessing that Marvel is gonna
obviously they're gonna want to
dismissed it has been quite a weird
story to follow because there's so many
different variables
um whereas normally when someone's under
these circumstances they can tend to
keep quiet Jonathan majors and his
lawyers especially they've been very
proactive and putting out evidence and
footage and though that's not always
worked
um it has you know made people at least
question exactly what's ha who's in the
right and so on and so forth now who are
text messages that drop that didn't
exactly clear Jonathan Major's name in
the way that he he probably thought that
they would and then they released
footage of the nightclub that showed the
person
um who he'd allegedly assaulted from the
footage was obviously difficult to make
out but it did look like it was
substantiating his claims that he hadn't
actually been violent and there's still
a lot of evidence to go through I don't
want to put my hat down and say oh yeah
believe him or whatever I think you know
everyone in these circumstances they
should just let these situations play
out instead of necessarily saying
exactly what side they're on because
you're gonna get you're gonna gain
nothing personally from just putting
your opinion out there and there's a lot
of things on social media at the moment
where I think people
feel because of the way social media
works and allows you to instantly put
your opinion out there that when serious
allegations come out rather than waiting
for the evidence or things to come out
and necessarily get cleared up they'll
just immediately put their thoughts out
there no real regard for you know due
process or letting things come to the
surface or hearing sides or anything
it's just very much I'm putting my
opinion out there without really knowing
the full story and it seems today that
people don't really have the the thing
within them that says it's okay to say I
don't know and I haven't formed an
opinion on this yet and I think just
saying I don't know because no one knows
no one knows exactly what happened and
there's lots of situations going on at
the moment controversies in media where
we probably will never know exactly what
happened because we weren't there and
evidence can get twisted you know
statements Witnesses so on they can
change narratives but they're never
going to be 100 and I think if you have
that a little bit of doubt in you if
it's a serious if it's a serious
allegation and something is going on
that's very dark with it I think it's
perfectly fine to say I don't know yeah
I'd rather just not State my opinion on
it and align myself with something that
could turn out to make me look very
stupid for doing it
um I'll see at the moment there's lots
of people being like you're in a cult
you're brainwashed if you if you don't
question this narrative or if you go
along with this person it's like well
both sides could be brainwashed because
they're jumping to a conclusion without
fully knowing the full story and
I think I think in general everyone is
brainwashed to a certain extent in some
degree but just social media just lets
you instantly put your opinion out there
and often you don't need to do it you're
not going to gain anything from doing it
so it's totally fine to stand back let
the situation play out and personally I
think you know just keep quiet until we
know that the results Marvel have done
that as well they've not actually
condemned Jonathan majors has said
anything yet they're just letting him go
through the process of trying to clear
his name before firing him or making a
statement on it obviously if the trial
goes badly
um you know it's they're going to be in
a really difficult situation if the case
gets dismissed I think it will sway a
lot of people around to his side you
know you're always going to get people
who will just be like well I don't
believe it and I think he's the bad guy
and they'll stick with that forever
because of possibly certain things or a
certain view that they have the world
shaped by their own experiences and but
yeah it's a very interesting case and
it's just this this PR well it's not
really PR thing but the footage come out
of the fight and yeah lots of things are
kind of just it just seemed with all the
pr stuff they'd been putting out that
there was an argument there that they
tried to do something else to get this
story out there
I mean I completely agree with you man I
think people get so married to their own
opinions very early on I I it's
understandable to me if
you or I or anyone goes well for what
I'm hearing I'm leaning this way
that's very different though than making
a definitive sentence of what did or did
not happen or what is or isn't actually
the truth to a situation right like
people might see what's been coming up
well from what I'm hearing I'm leaning
this way but I still don't know I think
that's very important to knowledge and
we all have our own biases and I think
what's really important is to be
self-aware of whatever biases that we
ultimately have because that can factor
in it could be a personal experience
emotional experience it can be
attachment to said celebrity as well
because that's the the other part of the
culture that we live in you know um
we've brought in just the way media you
know media places report stuff as well
if they have a certain base and they
want to appeal to that so you're gonna
see that as well and that that's on both
the right and left as well they they
will they know exactly who watches their
stuff and they will kind of push the
story into fitting that narrative so
that that viewers on turned off by and
it kind of fits in with their values in
there the way they see the world and
anyone in entertainment journalist
YouTubers will often do it as well you
know we see it all the time with stuff
like this you know we saw with without
diving too deep into this like Russell
Brand situation there are people
instantly who
believe that Russell Brand is innocent
like instantly made up their minds and
then and then completely went no here's
what's really happening and it's like
guys we've got to hear things out we got
everything we got to hear out we got to
see how things ultimately play out like
what Jonathan Majors there was something
else that happened recently where the
ins I think it was Insider they got some
video evidence that apparently the D.A
was sitting on for several months and
this video evidence really shows uh this
is what the lawyers the attorney is of
course claiming that it really proves
his his innocence and
you know if that's what they're
releasing it right now would Jonathan
Majors is a attorney and what they're
really focusing on
because they can't be releasing every
single detail obviously something that I
think we all have to keep in mind is
that really trying to win back the court
of public opinion as much as possible
that that's very evident as to what
they're what they're aiming to do at
least that's what I believe that's
that's how it's coming across because
especially if they don't ultimately
um if if they decide if the motion is
ultimately denied
you know it's like okay well what does
the prosecution have uh that we don't
know about we've got to just wait to see
how things ultimately play out on
everything like what happened with that
70s Show actor everything played out and
it's pretty obvious what happened on
that there was it
that right there was very clear on what
actually happened so we gotta let
something like this ultimately unfold
plain and simple plain and simple man
and obviously Ashton Kutcher and Mila
Kunis they got in trouble a lot this
week and yeah I think that kind of shows
the extent of how how much respect you
need to give to things like this you
know you get a movie review wrong okay
we'll let you off your opinion is your
opinion stuff is a gets more serious and
we don't like reporting on it in general
I mean we'd much rather come out and
talk about box offices and trailers but
when this dominates the media cycle
especially due to the strikes it makes
it difficult to avoid it yeah I think
the culture War just kind of has people
immediately jumping to certain sides and
it makes it difficult I personally don't
think that if you have good critical
thinking skills that you make up your
mind instantly off something without
seeing the full evidence or the
allegations I personally believe that an
intelligent person would normally wait
to see how things go and change their
mind if the circumstances change I feel
like there's a lot of tribalism at the
moment as well on social media people
have very much made up their their mind
on what side they are and they'll often
go with that narrative because it suits
them and what their beliefs are and it's
very it's very rare that you actually
see someone change their mind and often
even if they're proved wrong rather than
just going you know what it I have
changed my mind it's different they'll
actually dig into their position stick
with that even if it's wrong and this is
kind of how you know debates fall apart
and you you lead to two sides that just
can't agree on anything because they're
just so rooted into their opinion to the
point that even the facts don't actually
change what they're feeling and thinking
which is difficult to navigate
um and often leads to lots of big
disagreements over things that you know
you could probably agree on certain
parts of it but you you just don't and
yeah it leads to more Division and
unfortunately that's kind of where we've
hit now there's lots of cancellations
going off the back of that another thing
that's been canceled Taiko or TT Star
Wars movie that rpk has put out a report
on his patreon exclusive patreon saying
that the Taiko watiti Star Wars movie is
dead see I've seen this coming for
months Greg I mean lucasfilm just seemed
to announce a movie got a director on
board they're loving it they're gonna
get involved
you've seen in the case of Josh tranx
Boba Fett movie
dnd's Star Wars Trilogy Ryan Johnson
Star Wars Trilogy Kevin feige Star Wars
movie Rogue Squadron the lot we've seen
it in all them what do you think this
actually says about the state of Star
Wars in general is it a good thing that
they're actually being cautious in
canceling these projects if they don't
go so well or should they just not
announce them till they're actually in
production
I think the latter unless they're really
really confident because if I'm not
mistaken what Tito is still working on
the script the last time we was asked
about it it was a constant work in
progress and
it's really sad what happened after Thor
love and thunder for Taiko YTD because
he suddenly became a horrible director
to everyone when he's had so many good
movies he's done a lot of great work
even in the Star Wars realm he's uh I
mean yeah he plays um oh my God IG which
number is it 11. he's IG 11 yeah yeah
his ig-11 he's directed episodes of the
Mandalorian if I'm not mistaken he
directed the finale of season one uh if
I'm not mistaken about that and I think
he's had a great track record outside of
the Thor love and thunder response he's
had a phenomenal track record
and a lot of people are are here being
like good good he wouldn't and I think
he would have done a I know this is not
popular opinion especially after what
people have said about because he didn't
turn like the Mandalorian stuff he had
the one little banter bit with the
Stormtroopers and then hit baby Yoda but
it wasn't something that put the
audience in an uproar over it right and
I think he could have delivered an
interesting Star Wars movie I feel like
he would have not gone too off the walls
hopefully that's my hope
um but yeah I think uh these um the
crazy amount of announcements I can't
think of a franchise that's had more
announcements than Star Wars of things
that just do not come to fruition it's
yeah I think it's a tie between those
guys in DC to be honest because I
remember DC was announcing like black
Hulk Steven Spielberg movies and stuff
like that and obviously Green Lantern
like they're finally making it I think
but there's been so many characters that
they announced that didn't get anywhere
the cyborg movie but yes Star Wars
probably has more and I think what they
tend to do is they gravitate towards
creators who are very popular In the
Heat of the Moment think let's give
these guys a Star Wars movie all those
names are listed before they all got
given projects when they were at the
height of their popularity you know D
and D were on season seven of Game of
Thrones and I think they actually
sabotaged
season eight they were originally meant
to have Eight Episodes I think and then
they kind of cut it down to six they
were like we can get the story done in
six
um and they sabotaged that themselves to
work on the Star Wars Trilogy or film or
whatever it was and yeah it just it
doesn't go anywhere and I think the next
cancellation that you'll probably hear
is James Mann Gold's Star Wars film
which was announced very recently that
was before Indiana Jones and the dial of
destiny released and then it's been one
of the biggest box office bombs of all
time for the company
um so yeah I can't see them sticking
with that I think
I think they they have this pattern of
you know Patty Jenkins is another
example where Wonder Woman boom big
success signer up to Star Wars Wonder
Woman 1984 drops
yeah keep working on it definitely gonna
make it and they just have this habit of
getting people Ryan Judson again signing
them up when they seem popular and then
as soon as that star stops shining Ryan
Johnson Trilogy of films I totally
forgot about that yeah there's so many I
I think with DC they've probably had
more movies get canceled but the
differences with Star Wars they tend to
announce a creative team alongside well
at least like the directors they tend to
announce not just the movie but also who
they have attached to helm the film or
or subsidiary franchise or whatever and
so that puts a bigger Spotlight on it
whereas DC I'm like oh yeah they
announced this this and this and and
then we just kind of forget I mean even
though James gonna take it over they've
obviously canceled a crap ton of
projects and change the direction you
know uh but yeah with Star Wars like
yeah we've had Patty when you think
about like the director's names
associated with stuff Patty Jenkins
James Mangold Ryan Johnson Taiko ytt
um I know philor and Chris Miller
different situation sometimes I feel
like I think a lot of us might agree
with this that Studios sometimes take
the wrong lessons from things you know
cinematic universes became such a thing
that people tried doing because of
Marvel after Batman Begins a billion
people start like everyone get a got a
fresh dark origin reboot of every
character you know uh and and they they
have the Lando series that like they've
changed Lando from a movie is it wait
what was it it's a it's a movie to a
show now or it's a show to a movie I
forget so it was a series they had a
whoa it was it was a series
um that was my watch going off there the
watch is talking so there was a series
yeah that was originally Lando had it
had a screenwriter attached to it and
then they found out that they'd been
fired through Donald Glover's social
media and that his brother was now on it
and then it's just been announced that
it's actually going to be a movie now
instead of a series which I personally
think is the better way to do it I don't
think it's gonna be a massive success
you know solo didn't exactly do new
numbers but I feel like doing this it
will at least make money because I
personally don't feel I'll understand
how this stuff that just goes straight
to streaming I don't really understand
how that makes money might get some
subscribers in might keep people you
know renewing their subscription but I
think the the best model to go with is
to release it in theaters
sell it digitally sell it physically and
then drop it on streaming I think that's
the best way to do it instead of just
chopping that out and going we're making
a series that's just going straight to
streaming I mean I will look forward to
it all depending on whatever that first
trailer is if it looks like they because
you know Donald Glover is going to be I
think it was his brother who's writing
it right so I imagine that Donald Glover
will have a lot of creative input on
that and as we all know that Donald
Glover he he is a just some other type
of creative anomaly he's something else
entirely and he's had his experiences
with
franchises going awry I mean he had that
whole Deadpool animated series situation
uh I'm surprised he would be back on
board for this if he wasn't guaranteed
some level of creative control
especially after being a part of the
Solo movie experience
so my one inkling of Hope is that okay
I'm not really looking to be honest I'm
not really looking forward to this movie
but I love Donald Glover and if the TR
if they actually do go into production
if the trailer looks unique and
different and oh they are doing some of
the they let the Glovers have this their
strange idiosyncrasies surrounding this
creative
Ingenuity on display here then all right
I'll be on board but if it just looks
like
another thing in Star Wars I'm just I'm
really I'm currently like mildly
interested in it cautiously optimistic
mildly interested is where I'm at I
think it's going to get canceled I think
it'll be another project that stalls out
no one will get you know it'll never
really get going they might write your
script or something it'll get shifted
about from studio studio it'll be in
developmental for for years and years
and then just not get released yeah
that's pretty much par for the course
with a lot of Star Wars things now
speaking of killing the hype the Aquaman
trailer has just dropped well it hasn't
just dropped but it dropped last week
last Monday we had a trailer release for
the trailer I covered it didn't really
get many views I started feeling like oh
crap this is not looking good so I
didn't bother covering the main trailer
because I also felt like I'd just be
repeating myself because I talked about
a lot of the things that I would talk
about that anyway the trailer released
didn't really do that well view eyes
um I know a couple of YouTubers who did
breakdowns on it they're not happy with
the views they're not like furious and I
bloody hate Aquaman they're like the
views could have been better it seems
like the hype has kind of died down
about it and I don't really see many
people talking about it obviously my you
know my piss my perception of the
world's based around what I'm shown and
what I see and what I encounter but how
are you feeling Greg you you did a
reaction to it how did it go
I I mean view wise it like it's at a
100K views which is cool
um I'm appreciative of it
I'm going to give you guys some numbers
here then I'm gonna give you my opinion
on the trailer
Aquaman
the official trailer Aquaman the lost
kingdom official trailer
12 million views
that's really not a lot for how much
this movie cost on the DC Channel
on the DC official Channel
Blue Beetle
28 million views
the final trailer for Blue Beetle and
historically speaking generally
generally
a second trailer which unless the second
trailer is massively different it shows
you something like totally
groundbreaking you know
um generally a second trailer much less
views right
the final trailer for Blue Beetle 21
million views
so right now the Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom trailer
currently is
I mean it's a little bit more than half
of what the final trailer for Blue
Beetle is it's not a good start
um I I just don't like for like yeah
Greg because I thought I'd pull up a
more recent one the Marvel's trailer the
first one 21 million
um so it's kind of doing yeah it's not
doing crazy numbers and we kind of know
from the reception at least that people
don't seem to be wanting breakdowns on
it no man I mean the the trailer itself
it's it's a it's good like it's a yeah
it's good it's a good trailer
again though and I've said this a
billion times here on this podcast there
are some people who obviously are like
like you got your hard course we're
gonna watch it you got people who love
that first one and they're gonna watch
it
um because a lot of people the sentiment
is this this look I like that it feels
like a like a direct follow-up to the
first one sure at the same time
I don't know I've walked away from it
going it's a good trailer the effects
are good
it's like a thumbs up for me on that It
ultimately doesn't feel anything that
different from the first movie it really
doesn't feel that different
um a lot of it feels like a little bit
repetitive it you know when you when you
compare kind of
this Avatar in the Avatar The Way of
water has a very it has a much bigger
Gap in between release dates a much
bigger Gap
and for a long time before way of water
uh even had their trailer people were
going why would people give a about
this No One's Gonna care it's gonna flop
then you see those trailers
and you go oh they're actually doing
something different with this oh they
actually have something unique about
they weren't even like telling you what
the plot is of the movie but you could
sense that they were doing something
with a lot of Ingenuity they were doing
something Innovative still that they
were still going to be attempting
something very unique regardless and you
could you just got the impression and
the movie was a box off success
this trailer didn't do anything that
different for me compared to like okay
for the weight it just feels like
another DC movie now and with the
rhetoric around DC with the way people
talk about DC as a whole from the guts
uh The Flash movie Blue Beetle this is
not doing it any favors I don't I'm
gonna watch it obviously I'm gonna watch
it I'm gonna go with an open mind and
hope for the best but right now the
trailer doesn't look it didn't do
anything to feel that special
comparatively to the first movie other
than yeah it's
a sequel but it doesn't feel that
different or it doesn't feel that
different doesn't feel that exciting
other than cool visuals and looks fun
which is what we've said for the Flash
trailer what we said for Blue Beetle it
looks fun and it's got good visuals
that's always said and that's exactly
what we're saying about this right now
I don't know if anyone was saying the
flash had good visuals for the trailer
actually there were some visuals in the
chair to look good what what visuals in
the trailer visuals were better than the
movies visuals that's what that's what I
was saying so actually we watched The
Flash today the 4K for it arrived early
so I thought I'd put that on
um yeah I did enjoy it you know it's
weird how stepping away from something
kind of foggies your mind on it a bit
like The Dark Knight Rises is the
perfect film I think at that exemplifies
this whenever I'm watching it I think
this is actually incredible I can't
believe it I hate on this movie and then
as soon as I step away I'm like man was
it wasn't that good uh no to be fair I
do quite like The Dark Knight Rises as
well but yeah re-watching it today you
know I actually I did I did enjoy it
um it was just the effects I kind of
lost it and the fact that characters
like you know Batman were Ben Affleck's
Batman Michael Keaton's Batman Supergirl
Zod they're not really given proper
send-offs it's more kind of just you're
now erased from existence uh sorry yeah
you're out the timeline
and that kind of felt a bit you know
like we lost it and I feel like that was
we lost out on those characters because
of the reshoots and the changes that the
Universe was going because we know that
there was originally a post credit scene
involving Ben Affleck reaching out to
Barry if you look at the behind the
scenes stuff you can see that and it was
also it was originally meant to end with
Supergirl and Michael Keaton which then
they then swapped out for George Clooney
so it kind of felt like that and that
feeling is almost what I also feel about
Aquaman 2 it kind of feels like you know
when you're gonna watch a TV series you
your three seasons deep into it the
fourth season's coming and you're really
excited and then they announced that
they're canceling the show after the
fourth season it just completely kills
your hype for it and I feel like that's
what James Gunn's announcement earlier
this year did though I do enjoy watching
these movies it's kind of always in the
back of my mind that I I don't really
need to get invested in this I don't
need to give my full attention to it I
don't need to care because it's
something that
isn't necessarily going to go anywhere
and I know you should judge a movie on
its own Merit but when if that's the
case then just don't make a connected
Universe don't sell us that this is a
whole thing that all plays into each
other and you need to go and see all
these movies when you don't if they're
not going anywhere and I was actually
taking the kids out for a walk because I
I knew the trailer was coming uh I
decided I wasn't going to cover it
because I didn't feel like the the views
were going to be there for it and the
time that we would put into it as a team
you know me doing the writing the
audioing the whatever it launched at
five o'clock in the UK which is when uh
my team normally finishes up as well and
I'd have to get them to work overtime
and stuff like that and I kind of
thought I'm I'm not going to put those
resources into it because I don't feel
like we're gonna get the return on the
investment because unfortunately you
know YouTube's a business as well so I
took the kids out watched it on my phone
as I was walking along the street didn't
really like it thought it was okay but
wasn't Blown Away by it but then that
night when I got home watched it on the
TV I thought you know what this does
look good and I do enjoy that first
Aquaman film I thought it looks good
um but I feel like
it just feels I don't know like there's
not the obligation there to go and see
this because it's more of the same even
the villain's the same as the first
movie you know black matter we've the
other Stakes have changed it kind of
feels like that and just knowing what we
know the test screenings have been
really bad for this film yeah and
everything surrounding its kind of
there is a negativity around it you know
for example Amber Heard though they
showed a flash of her in that trailer
they clearly cut around her for the
family stuff at the start and it just
feels like they're they're putting this
out for the sake of putting it out
rather than being really excited for it
you know there wasn't that Fanfare DC
didn't come out guns blazing being like
we're releasing a trailer uh it just
feels like they're they're putting it
out for the sake of just finishing the
story
eating the next sandwich that the
last sandwich they have to get
through before they can reboot the
universe and that's kind of how I feel
with it um and just interestingly
I actually feel like this Marvel kind of
propped up the entire comic book movie
industry more than we give them credit
for I know we think that the biggest
Studio that they did really well but
them doing good movies that people
enjoyed that got people excited for the
next comic book movie and the next thing
that was going to be big and it felt at
one point like all these comic book
movies are so good I can't get enough of
them I have to go to the cinema and
that's what it is and when Marvel starts
doing badly they kind of kill the
interest in the rest of them as well
because
you know if if the they're not holding
up and propping everything up then
there's not the interest to see
everything else as well and I feel DC or
unfortunately in that box with a lot of
their characters maybe not people like
Batman and Joker but these Side
characters that don't necessarily have
that built-in fan base and have kind of
cultivated it over the last couple of
years that they haven't got those
Legions upon Legions of fans you know
Batman's been arguably the most popular
comic book character for the last 85
years
um I think it's I think 80 or 85 years
ago was when he was in 1939 I think it
was Detective Comics 27 don't quote me
on that I think Superman was a bitter
yeah I'm gonna show my quickly so
Superman I think was 1938 I want to say
um but yeah we're quickly Googling it
so
Action Comics yeah it was 1938 um and I
think Batman was the air after so these
Comics the characters have a built-in
audience my nerd card hasn't been
revoked thank God and they've got a
built an audience whereas I think these
other ones The Flash Shazam Aquaman Blue
Beetle take it all either audiences
there if the comic book movies are good
and they're interested in them and they
feel like they're gonna get a good
experience out of seeing them then
they're gonna go but you've had too many
misses with these mid-level characters
over the last couple of years where
people just don't feel the necessity to
see them anymore
I you know I gotta say though like
I think unless you really know the
potential of Black Manta from I don't
know Injustice games or comics
I don't see why you would be excited for
Black Manta I mean if you are cool
um good for you for me
exactly Yaya Abdul Mateen
exceptional actor
I think it's just one of the best we
have working today exceptional actor
what is character in The First movie
I did not think was a good character I
did not I like he barely left an
impression he kind of seemed like a uh a
thing that was just wedged into the film
that didn't need to be there uh and then
for him to come back when the first one
is like his brother or
it's hard to sell me on the stakes of it
maybe he's gonna be great I feel like
what they're trying to do is like a Loki
situation where yeah he was in Thor he
got defeated and now he's the big Baddie
for Avengers right but a big part of
Avengers was not really the fact that
the Avengers are versing Loki it was
just the First Time The Avengers are
coming together that was the exciting
part of it oh we're gonna get a big
battle sequence not really about that
villain and this movie's trying to sell
you on like weights and gravity to us
and Stakes but also it's fun and
exciting uh I don't think the the
element of stakes in a time where DC's
films register as inconsequential to the
Ultimate Experience when they are part
of connected Universe terrain
um unlike Joker and the Batman
I don't think it's doing a good job on
on selling us on the necessity of
experiencing this film personally that's
just where I'm at it's like you have you
heard of the anti-life equation it's
like the anti-hype equation so back in
the day when Co I say back in the day
about five years ago comic book movies
were building up towards something you
know what I mean Batman v Superman's
building up towards Justice League
Iron Man Thor Captain America Incredible
Hulk that's building up towards the
Avengers which then builds up to
Infinity War which then builds up to end
game this is idea of building now the
anti-hype equation is what DC are doing
at the moment which is they're building
up towards everything stopping so it's
like yeah we're building up towards
these movies not meaning anything and
then starting again which kind of kills
the hype and interest I I think that
James Gunn's you know statement again
we've said it to death on the podcast
but there was no need for him to say it
and the fact is now with the writer's
strike and the fact that you know VFX
artists they seem to be unionizing as
well I'd actually be surprised if it hit
the 2025 release date I think that movie
might get pushed back to 2026 you will
see they might you know
go all guns blazing no pun intended full
steam ahead into making that movie but I
think just with the delays and
everything that's going on they might
even have to push it back here which
will render James Gunn's statement
completely meaningless at that point and
I just don't feel like they needed to do
that and in general the lineup that they
had you know DC movies just weren't
quite clicking there wasn't it didn't
have the big characters coming out gun
you know Birds of Prey shirts nice
little spin-off thing Suicide Squad sure
yeah but they didn't bring out their
a-listers and that was what was so
frustrating and it's always been
frustrating about DC when you compare
them to Marvel Marvel didn't have the
lineup That DC had and DC had every
single character that they've ever owned
they weren't off with Sony you know what
I mean Superman was enough with
universal or something like that every
character they had was under their roof
and they didn't capitalize on it and
they focused
too much on you know these smaller Side
characters but back to back and it
didn't really feel like it was building
up to something didn't feel like it was
going somewhere and there was yeah I I
feel like Marvel did it really well
where
they'd have an event movie you know a
lesser-known character that they'd
introduce a big character that had
already been introduced that you would
go see and then maybe a lesser known
character than a big event film
and rather than doing that they've just
had psychi character side character side
character side character side character
side character like for a Superman movie
sequel 2013 was One Man of Steel release
and though we got Batman v Superman and
he appeared in Justice League that they
should have had just a solo Superman
movie at some point to kind of carry the
rest of those characters on his back to
to boost up those films in the same way
that Marvel did and unfortunately you
know
I think we obviously can't tell the
future but that the Aquaman box office I
think it would be very very surprising
if that did a billion dollars again I
think that when you look at it it's
pretty it's gonna be studied in the
future in business classes how DC
managed to tank a billion dollar
franchise that was built off the back of
a billion dollar franchise the all these
DC movies were so big and for them to
make a spin-off that made a billion and
then completely kill it I I just don't
know what's happened with it Greg do you
think Aquaman will hit a billion and if
not what what money do you think it's
gonna make I actually think
internationally it'll have a better shot
if if releases in China because I
believe the first one did really well in
China
it's the kind of in fact it kind of the
the the visuals of it sort of remind me
of like other International films like
other International fantasy films I've
seen and so even if it came in at like
I mean how much does it need to make to
profit like 600 a million I'd imagine
some something like that
I'm gonna guess 500 million worldwide no
no I'm gonna go 600 million worldwide
I'm gonna be generous 600 million
worldwide That's My Hope
I was thinking 500 million I was
thinking it's going to do exactly half
of the first movie that was kind of
where I feel like the views are half
there the hype in the universe is half
there and that's gonna feel where I I've
fallen and how I feel it's gonna do
trailer views are so bad over there so
bad
um and that's that's the biggest
Telltale sign man it like it really
doesn't matter I know we had a big
discussion about the impact of Rotten
Tomatoes
but
I don't know those trailer reviews are
hor like horrible for what it needs to
make it needs to do better than Blue
Beetle you know
um yeah unfortunately that's the case
and they've delayed the marketing so
much that you know it's no way home
played it really well where they held
off their trailer till right until they
needed to drop it and then they dropped
it and everyone's so hyped that it
exploded
Aquaman uh they've delayed it so long
and for it to be releasing this soon as
well and there's so little hope for it
that that is a bad sign
um but it is opening over Christmas you
know there's not much competition for it
I think it will do well internationally
I just don't think it's gonna be this
big massive event that the first film
was and yeah I'd be very surprised if it
did over
550. and I agree with you about what DC
has done so much they're indecision and
they're they're unconfidence in how to
handle Superman
was the biggest mistake they could have
ever made like that was they that was
their debut for the DC Universe and it's
Superman he's
I think yes I I full heartily agree like
okay with the amount of delays there was
no point in the James Gunn making these
announcements right I I agree with you
on that
same time the flip side is
the bigger of a breakup we can have from
the dceu the longer of a time than the
more
accepting I think audiences will be to
see a new Superman and it'll also allow
the creatives James gone to
ruminate develop a better Superman movie
even if a lot of it's just creative in
his head and not something he's actually
writing and submitting right
so I think that break can allow for a
better Superman movie because it's so
important to get Superman right he's
Superman he's next to Batman they're
Superman is the head of the DC you know
image
so to botch Superman uh the handling of
it I'm not saying Henry Cavill was like
was bought the witch Henry Cavill was
treated was botched
um saying that the way DC was like what
do we do I don't know how to handle it
was it was it's embarrassing of how they
handled Superman uh and so to get that
right I think one thing that I can agree
with James Gunn get aiming to get right
first and foremost
is get down your Man of Steel character
first because
that's he's DC man Superman is DC so we
need to get that right in the way they
handled it
and then just going to size seven
they're even ruining Batman dude like
flash hindered so much on Batman like
they like so much with Batman on that on
those trailers and it was a massive tank
so they're like don't ruin Batman now
man
they need to get right
and that kind of takes us into our final
story Greg and I'll let you get away Tim
Burton has just released an interview
with variety talking about his feelings
on the Nicholas Cage Superman cameo in
The Flash and all of the the ax films
and just AI in general so he recently
taught actually it wasn't variety they
released the story but the interview was
with the British Film Institute and he
discussed you know that that cameo in
the flash with Nicholas Cage is
obviously a reference to his film that
he worked on which was Superman lives
speaking of Superman as well
um so he said I don't have any regrets I
will say this when you work that long on
a project and it doesn't happen it
affects you for the rest of your life
because you get passionate about things
and each thing is an unknown journey and
it wasn't there yet but it's one of
those experiences that never leaves you
a little bit so he then went on to talk
about the um all of the things going on
with the flash which was built off a lot
of his movies you know not just Superman
lives obviously Batman Michael Keaton
was in that as well he was and and the
Flash owes a lot to what Tim Burton did
especially all those years back
um and he talked about the the recent
trend of reimagining films and
characters using AI cameos and so on
and he said it goes into another AI
thing and uh this I think I'm over with
the studio they can take what you did
Batman or whatever and they can
culturally misappropriate or whatever
you want to call it even though you're a
slave of Disney or Warner Brothers they
can do what they want so in my latter
years of life I'm in quiet revolt
against all of this I can't describe the
feeling it gives you it reminded me of
when cultures say don't take my picture
because it's taking away your soul what
it does is it sucks something away from
you it takes something from your soul a
psyche that is very disturbing
especially if it has nothing to do with
you it's like a robot taking your
humanity and soul that's what he felt in
regards to the Nicholas Cage Cameo Ai
and just in general how the industry is
going oh how would you like to summarize
your thoughts on that Greg this is the
first time hearing about it man I feel
bad for him yeah just it's breaking news
breaking news breaking news uh yeah very
very recently I feel I feel bad for him
on this regard I didn't even think about
that honestly and I feel like a selfish
viewer of how would Tim Burton have felt
about
this because I I for some reason my mind
Associated the Nick Cage Cameo more with
Kevin Smith that he like write was he
was he the one working on the script for
that he wrote a draft yeah he wrote a
draft
yeah he's talked about it at length
um great well not interviews but him
just basically standing on the stage
telling you all the ins and outs um and
I think it was John Peters I want to say
who wanted the giant spider included
which also appears in the film but
obviously you know
he put a lot into it Tim Burton he
worked on it for years it was his
follow-up to Batman Returns obviously he
stepped away
um for Batman Forever and didn't
continue with that character though they
did sort of keep things in the same vein
it was the same they like to play it now
like it was a disconnected universe and
off doing its own thing but you know
they kept Alfred they kept the
Commissioner Gordon actor they mentioned
a lot of things in those Tim Burton
films so it was definitely in the same
continuity at the time when it was
marketed because they didn't want to be
like we're making another Batman movie
back then you didn't reboot stuff that
often
um so yeah he got brought on by DC and
Warner Brothers to kind of work on
Superman relaunch him in the same way
that they just relaunched Batman and uh
just the struggles that he went through
and then yeah you can kind of see when
you you're creative it it does kind of
get taken away from you and I know a lot
of comic book writers and artists feel
the same way Alan were for example he's
very outspoken about it and but when you
listen to podcasts with them for example
Brian Michael Bendis I know he talked a
lot about his work on Winter Soldier
a lot of the things just get taken from
the artist and someone just makes those
elements without really fully even
asking the person who created it like
what were you trying to think on this
and what were you doing they just kind
of take it and write it in a sort of
it's a death of the author that that
sort of thing where it's no longer
belongs to them even though they created
it and made it successful which is yeah
it's just which is what I think this
comic creators have been grateful for
would weirdly enough as much as we've
been critical of DC in this
um in the movie realm they've been
intentionally promoting the comic books
and they I remembered uh oh my God who
is the guy who created Thanos give me
the gym Starling
um darling talked about like how he was
grateful to see like him actually be
credited for stuff when it comes to DC
you know and that's a cool thing that D
okay we gotta do DC credit for that
right now is especially with James Gunn
coming around you know when in his
announcement it was a lot of referencing
comics and authors you know and I I
agree with you on that front like DC
you're trying to get so much for
saying DC credited Jim stalling for
making Thanos you're gonna get so much
no I was saying I was saying who was the
guy who created it I was just that was
my first association with him
um so yeah the but when it comes to this
I mean The Flash movie was
I feel like the intent was to not eight
I I don't know if he really saw it did
he like because okay Edgar Wright he he
was talking about once when he was asked
about Ant-Man
um if he had ever watched that movie and
he likened it to he said no because he's
liking it uh it's like watching us I
think the word was like watching a uh uh
trying to watch my word here a tape of
your ex-girlfriend doing it with another
person right that's what he is
associated to uh and so he didn't want
so he would never want to watch the
movie because of that and and that is
kind of the same
sentiment that I'm getting here of yeah
he was attached to this for so long
they're taking it it's not like they to
me with the Nick Cage thing as weird as
the facts looked on the occasion I think
the intent was just to pay homage to a
certain extent but The Flash movie had
that weird thing where a lot of about
paying homage seemed to not register
well or kind of backfired to them for a
lot when it came to like George Reeves
or even like the Christopher Reeves
moment there's a lot of things that just
did not bode well for people I thought
the Nick Cage moment looked very strange
but when we're talking about the Michael
Keaton Tim Burton world it is that that
whole imagery the whole point was to pay
homage or to
or to set it into Tim Burton verse like
Tim Burton was adapting the Frank Miller
aesthetic and whatnot but it was very
much like this is a Tim Burton world
this is this is Tim Bergens and he want
and the whole point was to pay homage to
it and uh I can see how
yeah it's kind of like
weirdly it's kind of like when I would
watch a Tim Burton Disney movie today
where yeah I guess on the surface this
kind of looks like Tim Burton but the
soul of it is missing you know uh and
that's
and I heard I did hear Tim Burton talk
about that recently of how after Dumbo
he kind of became very much aware of
what his films had become
and Beetlejuice 2 is supposed to be
bringing him back more to the Tim Burton
that we all know or or like grew up
loving right uh more practical more
creative and I think they only had two
days left to film before the strikes
happen which is a real shitty position
to be in
um but yeah Tim Burton's had his
struggles with uh the Batman franchise
the in return for Batman Forever and
um I I think Batman return that's a
crazy it's it's weird when you look back
on the on the career trajectory because
Batman Returns the
the response it got at the time if I'm
not mistaken
was not as positive as the studios were
hoping because he really went down a
much darker path and it's harder to sell
toys for a movie like that but as the
years have gone on that the reverence
for Batman Returns has been so
exponential I know we've mentioned it
here before I I'd love that one I prefer
it over
this is not the most popular opinion I
like Batman 89 I do I I like batman89
I'm not as in love with it as everyone
else but I I do love Batman Returns
though
um and and I I feel I do feel bad for
him in this regard so yeah
I have a weird relationship with Batman
Returns because growing up in the 90s I
didn't actually have the Batman 89 VHS
my parents typed it off the TV but
because I was so young I was like two
years old when I watched it or something
they would stop the recording whenever
something violent happened and then
press record once that scene had ended
and I actually but I actually had the
Batman Returns VHS so I could watch that
properly so I always loved that didn't
really feel like I had a complete Batman
89 experience and then when I watched it
when I was older finally I just fell in
love with it and I thought oh this it's
like you know when they released
directors cuts of films that you already
really like it and it's like oh yeah
it's even better than I remember so that
kind of catapulted it above Batman
Returns for me but Batman Returns with
something I just watch all the time
through my childhood really enjoyed it
and to be honest it's probably more
messed up than the 89 film but just
because I had the actual VHS of it uh it
was like that but I thing it's I'm gonna
call it the Taiko watiti syndrome which
is but going on for years before it
um so Thor Ragnarok was a big success
they I'm guessing the studio held back
on what he could do but when the sequel
rolls around they give a much more
creative control and you can really see
the Taiko WaTiki personality come out
with that how Batman Begins another
example where you you can see Nolan in
that first movie but it there's a lot
more of a comedic like that that car
chasing that there's all the police in
our like cracking jokes are like tell me
what it looks like and then the tank
will drive by never mind it's like loads
of stuff like that and then you see The
Dark Knight where he's clearly being
given much more creative control it's
much more null in style and yeah it's a
lot darker and it's very serious and
there's not as many jokes in it there
are still some jokes but that's sort of
knowing jokes where it's just someone
saying something that only themselves
find funny uh you then jump to you know
Tim Burton that first movie probably
very controlled by the studio it was a
very very expensive film especially for
the time it was one of the most
expensive movies ever made
came out did a massive success at the
box office and then I feel for the
second one they were like do what you
want Tim you're a genius get get it get
in your bird eating Catwoman and stuff
and uh your weird clown orgy thing but
when poodle woman that has a little
poodle dog yeah all that get all your
weird Timber and stuff in if you want I
don't think
yeah exactly
um and I think they kind of regretted
that because they were famously trying
to sell Happy Meal toys and it was like
I don't know if the the penguin that
oozes black sludge out of his mouth it
is very child friendly
um so yeah it's kind of that but it is
very sad to see and I think the industry
in general is just kind of speaking out
against AI I mean Sean Penn came out
with a really crazy quote last week
where he was talking about it's like you
want to steal my
um you want to steal my appearance how
about I take your daughter's appearance
and we'll go from my friend's house and
have some fun it's like well Sean mate
it's not what are you implying here you
taking this to a bit of a weird place I
don't even have it done but I'm offended
right now yeah that was that was one of
those Sentiments of like I get your
point but
yeah maybe choose a different example
right now
the metaphor you're imagining right now
seems very very dark and twisted and it
might speak more about your personality
then you you're willing to let on
um so yeah kind of feel bad for Tim
Burton but this is you know when you
borrow a character from someone else or
a studio that owns an IP a franchise
asks you to do something you're kind of
beholden to what they then want to take
and do with it but like I said you know
I actually I did enjoy the flash I think
the First Act of the movie the the whole
Justice League thing uh it's okay but I
I think when they get to Wayne Manor
that's when I really start enjoying the
film and then the super the Supergirl
scenes are great and yet it's it's
better but you know
Tim Burton obviously has a much more
mistake in it and yeah just to hear him
be like they they up my It's
really hurting Nicholas Cage kind of sad
but yeah Craig any funnels I can imagine
when you're on the creative yeah I think
when you're on the creative side it can
I think in like in my in my view
I don't go oh they ruin Batman 89 they
ruin Batman Returns in my point and I
feel like for most people but I think
when you are the creative you could
probably watch it or see something and
go oh they ruined it you know they
ruined it for me on that personal
feeling so
I get it I uh I do I get it but you know
we'll see how this goes down it'll be
fine
that'll be fine I'm glad we could film
this today this was a nice
this was a nice conversation to happen
and we avoided all the controversy that
I cut out in the edit that we were gonna
talk about oh yeah and everyone no one's
the wiser no it didn't actually say
anything that bad guys I promise we'll
be back so yeah please if you've
listened this before I'm asking you your
job this week guys your job and you I
know exactly what you like you're like
oh I need to get stuff done before I
forget you need to go and like the
podcast give us five stars on Amazon
Spotify iTunes it really helps us out
keeps us going because we we've both
been a bit under the weather this
weekend and it hit a point where I was
like should we even bother doing it this
week but I thought no those loyal
subscribers out there they that they
will like this podcast sometimes so
we'll do it for them we do for you guys
um so yeah like the like the video
please it does mean a lot um and I hope
you guys have a great week who knows
what's gonna happen I've got to a point
now where I'll see a story pop up and
I'll put it down in my notes and it'll
get to about Thursday and I think oh
there's not much news happening this
week and then someone stupid will come
out with a being like I'm going back on
air with my show and it'll it'll all go
down like that and yeah the floodgates
kind of open to am so yeah thanks guys
for rocking with us again you want to
check out Greg's videos oh yeah real
rejects I watched one search away real
rejects just watch Bobby maybe I'll come
back next week and be like I watched it
was the best movie I've ever seen hate
myself for denying myself the pleasure
of Barbie and I wanna and not one thing
I'll see I see that some people will be
like oh you guys always have like
negative topic podcasts or whatever we
could have been way more negative with
the amount of that came out this
week you know already freaking
celebrities got in trouble over the
course of one week just constantly yeah
new Cycles from so many celebrities and
we barely touched it you know what I
mean like it was yeah it was non-stop
it was a lot of people and we might have
given like a sentence here there for a
couple of them but man it was it was it
was wild there's just how many
celebrities were just getting yeah how
much it
I feel like I know my audience pretty
well and I feel a lot of them are good
at detection and that they just
don't really want to hear that from us
anyway they kind of they they see us as
teammates just having a bro we'll take a
break from all the negativity if you've
taken time to listen to the podcast you
obviously want to get away from that
world so yeah we thank you guys for
rocking with us there was nothing on
Ashton Kutcher or Mila Kuna well
actually I think there was it was like
we have talked about it Greg I'm gonna
get comments saying you did talk about
it I'm so brief
and the one thing we didn't talk about
was the El muerto getting canceled so
I'm devastated
and in the podcast on a negative note
with the cancellation of el mueto oh no
but yeah thanks guys for sticking with
us uh let us know your thoughts on
Aquaman which we completely ripped apart
and we're really negative about and more
positive things like Oppenheimer
Crossing 900 million at the box office
it's gonna gonna get to the billion I
promise you I promise you but yeah guys
uh thanks a lot and see you next time
why